new questions about what happened in the
hours before last week's deadly shooting
at a high school in oxford michigan
james and jennifer crumley the parents
of the accused shooter are in custody
after law enforcement tracked them down
in detroit they've been charged with
four counts each of involuntary
manslaughter for allegedly allowing
their son ethan access to the gun that
he's accused of using to kill four
fellow students michael george is in
pontiac michigan michael good morning
vlad good morning the crumblies and
their son are all inside this jail and
they've all pleaded not guilty and the
school district faces more questions
about allowing the accused gunman to
remain in school after they say he was
found in class with a disturbing note on
the morning of the shooting
a manhunt led officials to a vacant art
studio in this detroit warehouse where
james and jennifer crumbly the parents
of the accused oxford high school
shooter were captured early saturday
morning it certainly raises my eyebrows
the couple was arrested inside a
commercial space connected to this man
65-year-old andre shakura after failing
to appear for an arraignment on friday
he didn't know that there were active
warrants through his attorney shakura
said that he didn't know the crumblies
had been charged he thought he was just
helping his friends they had received
death threats all week so they wanted to
go somewhere where they could have some
peace for a few hours they were never
fleeing prosecution the couple appeared
in a court hearing on saturday where
their attorneys insisted they had not
run from authorities they were terrified
they were not at home they were figuring
out what to do in a letter sent to
parents saturday superintendent tim
throne said that one day before the
shooting a teacher reported ethan
crumbly to school authorities after
seeing him looking at ammunition on his
phone
school officials say they reached out to
crumbly's mother but received no answer
that day
but according to prosecutors phone
records show jennifer crumbly later sent
her son a text that read lol i'm not mad
at you you have to learn not to get
caught
prosecutors also say that on the morning
of the shooting a teacher saw crumbly
drawing images of a handgun and a person
who appeared to be shot with disturbing
phrases including the thoughts won't
stop help me the school said his parents
were called in and he allegedly told
officials the drawing was part of a
video game he was designing his parents
were told to enroll him in counseling
within 48 hours and they refused to take
him home
but the school district also says
crumbly's answers led counselors to
again conclude he did not intend on
committing either self-harm or harm to
others
he was sent back to class and
prosecutors say just hours later began
firing a gun
and shot 11 people killing four i don't
know that anybody will feel safe sending
their kids back to school until they
know exactly what happened here
and the school district wants a third
party investigation into the incident to
look into all the interactions the
accused shooter had with staff and
students michigan's attorney general is
volunteering to take that on gail
michael thank you so much